What's going on everyone? Welcome back
to another video. Today we're going to
be covering how to trade trends the
right way.
This is what the entire video is going
to be based off. 80% of the time price
is trending, it will continue its
direction. 20% of the time price is
trending, it will reverse direction. For
those of you that prefer continuation
trading, you are automatically at an
advantage. For those of you that prefer
reversal trading, you're automatically
at a disadvantage. I'm going to explain
that throughout the video, what it means
and how you can better increase your
odds trading regardless of what your
winning strategy, your trading model,
whatever it might be. If you want to
know where this concept comes from, it's
directly from the Fibonacci sequence.
Golden ratio also referring to
everything in nature essentially being
perfect.
When we correlate that directly over to
the market, obviously there's not a
spiral on here, but everything is
essentially in a perfect trend 24/7. You
can draw as many lines as you want on
the chart using the trend line tool, but
you're always going to find some kind of
trend where something is making a higher
low or a higher high
all within a trend.
In an ideal trading scenario, you will
have five retest of a trend with the
fifth retest being the losing one.
Meaning that four retest after that
trend is established, those are the four
that you win on. The fifth one, one out
of five or that 20% is the one that you
lose on. Now you know the concept, but
how do we go about trading it? We're
going to take a look at gold for today.
Very clearly in an uptrend, 3.6% up on
the day, up the entire day. couple of
pullbacks here and there. Where are my
entries? Where are my exits, stop
losses, whatever it might be. Now, for
me personally, I like to add the 50%
retracement onto these levels. And that
is where I like to enter. For last
night, it was in an accumulation phase,
so pretty much no trades there. What I
did do was I slapped a pretty nice trend
line bottom on that. Tried taking an
entry on the range bottom. It ended up
working quite well.
miss the entire move up at 1 to 3:00 am
in the morning is what it is. Where do I
go about entering? The beautiful thing
about this concept is that it lines up
with whatever your trading strategy
might be. Unless you are a reversal
trader, unfortunately, this will not
help you. If you are looking for
continuations, very much like I do with
the London 50, you slap a 50% mark on
there. You're looking for price to go
up, come down, retest that 50%, and then
continue. Obviously, that was not the
case for today. So, what do I do with
these Asia? What do I do with these Asia
trades that has worked so well for me
recently? Now, taking a look at gold
from Gloex open on Sunday, I simply like
to wait for a pullback on whatever
candle it might be. You might want to
call it chasing the trend, whatever it
might be. I wait for a pullback. If
price is up 50 points on gold like it
was on Sunday's open, it's probably not
coming all the way back down to 50%, let
alone coming back down even 20%. So, I
like to go down no further than the
15-minute time frame and simply look for
a wick once the candle opens. Or for
Gloex opens, I like to wait for 30
minutes. After that 30 minutes, I look
for a retracement of typically 50% of
that second 15-minute candle. Now, this
doesn't have much of a rhyme or reason
to it for a glowex open. Obviously,
you're going to have trends up, trends
down. It's as simple as just waiting for
a 50% correction. I enter. I have a
fivepoint stop loss. That's my model for
Asia session for GloEx open.
In this case, I entered at about 4675.
My stop loss was five points. This was a
three-point wick underneath 50%.
got a beautiful continuation up. Hit a
12point win. I ended up securing for I
believe $20 on 20 Apex account. So still
400, but besides the point. Essentially
what you're doing or what I do is I look
for the open of GOPEX 6 PM EST.
What is the trend? What's the
establishment of the trend on those
first two 15-minute candles, the first
30 minutes? Mark out the 50% of the
second candle.
drag that to the right and you're
looking for price to pretty much just
retrace to that second 50%.
This case, I did take an entry on
Thursday last week. This one ended up
being about a sixpoint win, $60 over 20
accounts. Now, it's not a crazy high
uh riskreward or whatever you want to
call it depending on your sizing, but
what it does get you is a consistent
win, consistent small win that starts
your day green. So, we mark out even if
you want to do the full bar, you mark
out 50%, sometimes you're going to get
the full retracement. Sometimes you're
not. In this case, it did retrace right
to 50% of that entire 30 minute move.
And then you got a beautiful
continuation down. I took this trade at
I believe about 4617, five point stop,
did not get hit, and then it ended up
crashing all the way down to 4587.
missed out on another 40 points or $400
on one micro gold.
This is just my own uh play or spin on
the strategy.
It lines up with whatever you're trading
for a trading model. Let's say you do
changes say delivery for a reversal
strategy. This isn't really going to
help you all that much, but it can give
you a clear picture of where price might
go for let's say a price target on a
reversal. you had a change and say a
delivery on this 1845 candle. Okay, go
and slap that 50% mark in. That should
be where price pushes up to. That's a
good price target for you. Now, that's
just an example.
The whole concept itself is that you do
not want to be fading the trend. Very
clear depiction of what it hap uh what
it shows on Tuesday, January 13th is the
trend was down for the entire day on
gold. Now, the question I get asked most
often is, "How do I determine what the
trend is?" How do you know what the
trend is? It's as simple as just going
looking to the right. What is the gap up
for the day? Or waiting an hour, two
hours, three hours. What's the direction
of those candles? You can also go and do
this on Q's. Very clear direction for
today's price action.
2 point um one two% down in the day.
However, we were also gapped down 1.7%
to start the day. Even though the trend
is up from pre-market, if we go and take
a look at MNQ
on the larger time frame, oops, let's
pull that up there. We can see that this
has just continued to trend down the
entire time. Now, let's say you like
trading trend line resistance. Go and
slap a resistance line on there and
there's your trend. Those are your
entries. Just wait for price to retest
up to that. You know that the trend is
down. Very slim chance that price
continues through that trend line
resistance. One and five.
Slap the bottom uh bottom line on there.
You're not looking to take bounces.
You're only looking to play the
direction of price. You can go into
whatever time frame you want. You can go
into the one minute. You can go into the
five minute. The shorter the time frame,
the shorter the entries. In this case,
if you were on the five minute time
frame, this was a trend up. If you were
on the three minute time frame, also a
trend up. Even on the 15 minute time
frame, trend up into a trend down. So,
every retest to the downside,
maybe not look for long because the
overall trend is to the downside. But as
soon as this starts pivoting to the
downside again, you're looking for wicks
or green candles to enter into. Have a
conservative stop loss, 10 points, 20
points, whatever you want.
Uh, one of the concepts that I came
across for this strategy as well or this
concept is have your stop loss be the
top of the previous 15-minute candle or
the low of the previous 15-minute candle
depending on what the trend is.
Mainly for uh overnight futures on gold.
And this is why I've been trading. I
think I've had two losses over the past
two weeks, three weeks maybe since I
started alerting them within the
Discord. You're just looking for that
first 30 minutes of direction. Now, if
it's something like this, you should be
able to infer that, hey, this is not
really a trend. This is sideways. This
is an accumulation phase. You can also
get that from just scrolling out and
seeing, oh, price has been sideways for
the better part of five, six trading
days. Probably not going to trade within
that. But as soon as price breaks the
accumulation, then we can start looking
for a nice run to the upside or
downside.
All you want to be doing is make sure
that you're maintaining trend. And it
all comes back to 80% of the time price
is trending. It will continue in that
direction. 20% of the time it will
reverse.
You're just looking for continuations.
You can have whatever size stop loss you
want as long as it's not blowing your
account obviously, but you want to make
sure that you're maintaining the
direction of that trend. Again, for me,
I like measuring out 50% lines.
Depending on where price retrace to it
retraces to 50%, that typically is the
best entry I can get. It's not always
going to retrace to 50%. We go over
again, just an example for that first 30
minutes of uh Gloex open. This one would
have been a loss. It was going sideways.
There wasn't really a trend on this
quite yet. As soon as that started
trending to the downside, then you start
looking for pullbacks to go short into.
And it's as simple as just being able to
draw two channels
parallel to each other. And that gives
you your overall trend to the downside.
Okay. Every time it hits the top, I'm
going to look to short it. I'm not going
to long it on the bottom because that's
going to probably lead it lower. I don't
want to be inversing the trend. The most
helpful tip that I can give in this
video, if you guys have made it this
far, is just make sure that whatever
time frame you're trading on, whatever
way price is moving, you are not trying
to go long or short. You're not trying
to catch a knife.
plenty of examples of people that I know
that do this on the 15 minute time frame
regularly and they consistently blow
accounts. I was even at this point one
time in my trading career where you look
at the chart. Perfect example, today's
uh PM session on Q's and you say to
yourself, "No way this is going lower.
I'm going to buy it. Just going to be a
quick scalp.
I'll risk $50, but I'm looking for price
to make a miraculous 400 point move back
to the upside. Not really going to risk
too much with it, though. And then you
do that trade 10 times over, and now you
no longer have a futures account. So
again, what you're looking for is just a
continuation in trend. You want price to
continue in one direction. Four out of
five times, eight out of 10 times, 16
out of 20 times it is going to continue
in that direction.
Only four out of 20, two out of 10, one
out of five times it is going to inverse
and make a reversal. So if this was a
trend up from pre-market,
we had say one, two, three, four
retests. The fourth one ended up failing
and that was a reversal. But you still
got three really solid plays out of the
longs.
And then once you get stopped,
your stop loss is at a point where it
will validate the trend is reversing.
So if you get stopped out on a trade,
you're no longer looking to continue in
the uptrend. You're no longer looking to
continue in the downtrend. You're
waiting for a new trend to establish.
And again, that all comes back to the
Fibonacci sequence, which is very
relevant in trading, very relevant in
numbers. I mean Google search you have
the seventh option here being one that's
on trading
everything comes back to just ideally
being perfect in terms of this Fibonacci
sequence Fibonacci spiral
and that is how it determines what the
trend is and you can also go if you
wanted to you could slap a Fibonacci
retracement on here and maybe those are
where your your entries are. Let's say
we mark out the entire Fibonacci
retracement bottom to top and we enter
at each respective Fibonacci level 0 78
61.5 38 whatever it might be. Obviously
that's just a wild idea thrown out there
but you get the point.
Again, if you made it this far in the
video, you want to maintain trend
direction. You want to maintain trading
with the direction of the trend. You do
not want to inverse the trend. and
reversing the trend is how you're going
to lead to blown accounts. That is my
strategy for trading Asia gold, Gloex
gold, whatever you want to call it. Wait
for that 6 p.m. open. Okay, great. That
6 p.m. open. If that doesn't determine
direction, you can wait. Wait to seven,
wait to eight, wait to nine. As soon as
direction is shown, you're waiting for a
retracement to get into that play. Now,
these ones, pretty wide range on this.
might not have a fivepoint stop.
However, we are looking at a 15 minute
time frame. So, it's a little tricky to
back test. I believe I did end up taking
one on this Sunday the 28th.
I can almost guarantee I probably took a
short as soon as it ended up retracing
this candle. Once it did retrace that
candle, you can see once we hit 50%, it
had a 12point wick back to the downside.
that wick. Obviously looking at a
15-minute time frame afterwards doesn't
look like a win, but during that trade
that might have been five minutes within
the trade, 12 points on one micro is 120
bucks. I probably caught 40 to $50 of
that move at best. But that's the entire
concept right there. If you want to go
to larger swings and larger stop-
losses, then you can mark out the entire
trend line itself.
and your entries are at the top of that
trend line resistance and you're
targeting to the bottom of that trend
line. Ideally, you look for a
continuation down. Uh great example here
as well. We'll do this being the last
one. The trend is continuing to the
upside. It's very very simple to draw
and there is always always always some
kind of trend happening. Sometimes
they're very very sharp. Sometimes
they're in accumulation trends.
Everything is within two parallel lines
and you are trading that trend at any
given moment. Hope you guys enjoyed this
video. I will end it off with the stat
again. 80% of the time price is
trending, it will continue in its
direction. 20% of the time price is
trending, it will reverse direction. See
you guys next week for another video.
Peace out.